so this is what they do they're just
lying to you it's all a big lie and
i want to get into in a moment why they
think they can lie to you
but just consider how far these lies go
the democratic national convention
believed that it was a good idea
to send a member a representative
to the native american caucus the native
american working group
do you know which prominent democrat
they sent
to the native american caucus to i
you know i know that you know you know
that i know that you know
take a listen hello to the dnc native
american caucus it is
such an honor to join you all today
liowatha herself there she is
pocahontas chief spreading bull
she this woman who had to drop out of
the presidential race
who was crippled going to the
presidential race in a way that she
never recovered from because she lied
about being native american
to get better jobs to advance in her
career she lied for decades and then it
turned out she's the whitest woman
that's ever walked the earth
they sent her as if none of that
happened
you remember at the time she took a dna
test she said i might be
one 1024th native american
she published this she sent this to the
boston globe as though that exonerated
her
that's how divorced from reality they
are that's how much they
think they can hoodwink you and they're
doing it again
doesn't matter now part of the reason
they sent liz warren in the democrats
defense is
who else are they going to get namely a
prominent native american
democratic politician at the national
level can you name me one
no of course not and and frankly
the whole democratic left-wing argument
on native americans is they're a
separate country it's their land they
shouldn't participate
in colonial american politics so they're
setting themselves up from the beginning
not to have any prominent
native american politicians also when
you divvy up the electorate and you make
your entire
base your whole coalition just about
ever more narrow identity victim groups
well then you have egg on your face when
you don't have a representative for that
victim group
i mean you know the victim groups divide
and divide and divide there's no end to
that
so eventually they're going to run out
of people to represent them they seem
already to have done that
that's why they had to send liz warren i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you